whenever des chances quand j'ai écrit
ces chansons je ne pouvais pas penser
qu'elle serait chanter en France au
Japon une french non vraiment jamais
c'est du classique maintenant
22 novembre 1962 concert au Carnegie
Hall de New York un certain Tom Jobim le
monde entier découvre alors rien de
moins qu'une nouvelle musique inspirée
par la samba et le cool jazz nez sur les
plages de Copacabana
la bossa nova
composer des plus grands
[Musique]
chemises
je sens l'influence de Claude Achille
Debussy
par Debussy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les classiques tu sais l'après-midi
d'infosne
[Musique]
la suite bergamasques les choses que je
jouais quand j'étais enfant
[Musique]
privilégié
je ne pouvais pas penser qu'elle serait
chantée en France au Japon une french
non on va manger
c'est du classique maintenant
il y a aussi les paroles en portugais
qui sont très bonnes et
incompréhensibles au reste du monde
le Portugais la langue des espions quand
tu espionnes tu parles en portugais car
personne ne te comprend
[Musique]
pourquoi
qui est la triche
[Musique]
qui parle de la statue le Rédempteur
Redempteur
les jours de mars de mars
[Musique]
dis-moi si on est dehors voir le ciel
c'est une nuit merveilleuse le ciel est
plein d'étoiles je déteste la musique tu
sais
qui ont chanté tes chansons
Jobim song
tu sais la femme de Joao Gilberto
de faire la première version de girl
from Ipanema oui la première version
anglaise oui oui c'est ça son père était
professeur d'anglais Tom maintenant tu
es assez vieux pour être fait une idée
précise tu as une maison qui domine la
ville tu penses quoi de la situation du
Brésil aujourd'hui
Campos Robert Campos a dit le Japon est
un pays très pauvre avec une vocation
pour la richesse et donc ils sont très
riches et le Brésil est un pays très
riche avec une vocation pour la pauvreté
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu